now we're recording yay Oh welcome to
Friday on its grace I don't have a
fright I race today because I left my
whole wallet in the Austin Airport after
South by Southwest so my cameras in
there with all of my footage
dumbass Monday is st. Patrick's Day and
every year if you don't know I on the
internet tried to shop down a beer in
honor of st. Patrick's Day and I have
flula and memory here with me today to
try and help me out memory help me out
last year Big Time exception I didn't
learn anything helping out you mean I
kicked your ass yeah blue-nose here with
us this year because Germans beer etc we
do it we're drinking a delicious water
called would like bootleg is this in
German bootless pudding it good but I
like to get my food every year I try to
recap what it means to shotgun a beer
and as far as I know and this is doing
it yeah okay you have to like to pack
and wrestle and get the carbonation
going a little bit you punch on your
hand put your mouth on it around let it
pop the top and then struck till it's
dry chuckling beers
no but that's all I we go boom and then
second behind us right okay
okay go music videos okay here we go
everyone these are clothes none of us
care about it hope three two one
[Music]
my heart skinnier I think I got better
what was he the saint of I don't know a
mirror on my cabinets yeah biggest
license I wasn't so drunk it's the one
why did why that's what everyone else
sounds like for every video they put on
the Internet
I don't know look at the Y and st. paddy
you're going straight like bum bum